hi my name is Javier Bardem and I feel
scared about being Conor O'Brien's
friend you should be scared you should
be scared it is uh it is great uh I mean
maybe the greatest honor of your life
I'm sure you've I haven't done any
research I don't know if you've won any
awards of any kind uh major Awards
um I've heard talk of an oscar but who
knows those things yeah who cares this
is the true honor of your life no no
listen everything has lead me to come
here today
I work hard for years for ages to be in
front of you man because I love you yeah
yeah yeah you know it was great this man
uh you would come on the The Late Night
show many times or over the years you
came on several times and you were
always so funny because you just spoke
from the heart and it was so fantastic
because you would look at me and you go
hey man your hair you look like a fool
[Laughter]
and the whole crowd would go crazy
because they're like yes Javier get him
get him he's like what is this what are
you doing man what are you doing it was
fantastic I would laugh so hard that on
the way to the podcast studio today
thinking about seeing Javier again I was
laughing and thinking about it that's
good yeah the only thing that I will ask
for in any promotion is I want to go and
see Conan O'Brien
that's so nice that is so nice here I am
today I'm so glad I'm sorry your dream
uh your dream has come true and uh
congratulations thank you so much I hope
it's really up up there as I imagine
well this is a problem now I have to I
used to have this problem with women
they would imagine that you know the
word without that I was a great lover of
course when did that get out well I kept
putting it out there okay I figured and
then of course uh there was always
disappointment and crying I was crying
often but you're here now it is so great
to have you here and we have to get a
few things out of the way because
um we have some major insane fans in the
room uh my friend here Matt and I'm
going to bring this up right now is uh
obsessed with James Bond movies all
right and and I agree with him he
maintains and I will back him up on this
we both believe that you may be
if not the best one of the greatest even
I don't think there's even a question
frankly that's Bond villain oh wow best
Bond villain and your performance in
Skyfall was so freaking insanely good
and I had all this mixture of qualities
where there were times where I really I
felt sorry for you you sucked me in and
then I felt sorry for you but then I
hated you and it was it just kept
swirling around what about you Matt you
well even just now when you said that
everything led up to this moment is very
much like what Silva says yeah uh
frankly I almost fainted yeah but
because because Conan is the most
similar thing to James Bond
I mean
exactly
yes and then I am very painful I'm going
to open yours I'm going to open your
shirt very soon and start carries in
your purchase Oh my God oh my God oh my
God I did that today is Craig can you
believe yeah I am the man who was
touching Daniel Craig's breast like this
close uh you touch his breasts that's
the way it goes yeah yeah it's funny you
always wonder how planned out was a
moment like that because it's such
you haven't seen that happen with James
Bond and it's this move it's this move
that's Crossing all kinds of lines it's
so shocking and I think is that the kind
of thing that's discussed beforehand or
can you just go for it with Daniel Craig
It Was Written but till the moment we
got on set and we start to put it on on
on our feet uh it was not we didn't know
how to achieve that moment so we just
and some Menders love rehearsal but he
said you know what we're gonna shoot it
let's see how he goes and Daniel is the
best partner ever he was having a blast
like he really wanted to to go as far as
we could as far as we as far as the
studio will let us go
uh and uh and I think the chemistry was
there because uh we liked being with
each other and playing with each other
and uh but uh I think Sam Mendes was the
the heart of the and the Holland soul of
the whole thing he really wanted to
create this uh uh profile of a villain
that you can relate to and it's more is
more reliable than also I thought uh
that your relationship with Judy Dench
you know as
that's Mom and and trying to relate to
James Bond that we all do this for you
know the queen is Mom and this is Mom
and and so there's that element to it
also and I thought it was one of the
most it's the most emotionally complex
relationship
uh with a bond villain and showed you
what these movies can do what they can
be it because we we grew when I was a
kid I grew up and it was just you know
you must die Mr Bond and and petting the
kitten and you it's a caricature it's
fun but you never thought of these kinds
of moments yeah absolutely and that
little walk you do from your monologue
intro is it true that they built that
set basically the length of your walk so
you could time that out well what I when
I got there the city was built so that's
not a lot that's a lie okay I have to I
have to walk I just want you to know I'm
a huge liar
that's why you are in this program this
podcast every day he says Conan I really
admire you
you're so funny and you're a good
looking too why aren't you in film he
says that all the time yeah
now the thing is it's true that I didn't
I never rehearse on on the set but once
I was there and I saw how far Daniel
Craig was sitting down on the chairs
like man how am I going to do this
and I'm gonna tell you we did it like
seven times and he was not there
so Sam and I we look at each other and
we said this is not
we haven't done it so and he said you
know what let's play the scene and at
the end if there is some time we'll go
back to it we play most of the scene
most of my side of the scene and then in
the last 20 minutes he said are you
ready I think we can make one of those
more yeah let's do it he put the camera
and I did it and that's the one it's in
the movie because my body was more
relaxed it was more it was more at least
yeah uh when the first thing in the
morning to do that for me was a little
bit of a shot oh wow and uh and and it's
funny because Daniel the camera was on
his shoulder and he was like rooting for
me because he was seeing me how I was
coming to the mark the end mark yeah and
I was making it happen yeah he was like
yes yes and at times you could take
these little baby steps to make it time
out but it works for the character this
kind of like almost a little Boot Scoot
and Boogie yeah yeah you can see uh it's
sometimes if you look really closely
Daniel Craig starts to high five
yeah and they had to they had to cut
around it and it's that got a little
awkward and um and not to just totally
fan geek out but in addition to that
movie one of my alts I'm idolize the
Coen brothers and then I think my
favorite of all their movies if I had to
if they said okay you get to pick one I
would say No Country for Old Men And as
as great as that cast was I know you
came on the show to promote it
and uh had the nerve to show a clip of
Anton chigur and then minutes after
showing that clip turned to me and told
me that my hair looked stupid
and I said wait a minute you're an
assassin who's who looks like Dorothy
Hamill on skates you know
but uh but it was such a it was such an
amazing moment for me because
you still I still had the more
ridiculous hair than Anton chigur it's
ugly